ciao mariners e benvenuti nella seconda
parte del video sui sosia il video
precedente vi è piaciuto un sacco e
siete stati proprio voi a farvi scoprire
altri sosia molto interessanti ma bando
alle ciance partiamo subito con la sosia
di marilyn monroe
allora lei si chiama susy kennedy e
alcuni di voi l'avranno già vista perché
ha partecipato al film io e marilyn di
leonardo pieraccioni è inglese se non
sbaglio ed è veramente identica l'altra
volta è detto aperto identica un sacco
di volte però è così è identica marilyn
monroe più guardo le foto del suo
profilo più mi rendo conto che
effettivamente la somiglianza è
spaventosa lei ovviamente ricrea anche i
suoi look e le sue pose il bianco e nero
comunque aiuta molto però di base devo
dire che la sostanza c'è perché è molto
molto simile a marylin per tutte le fan
design
abbiamo anche il suo sosia siete pronte
cioè ragazzi ma parte che è un bono
ovviamente come già in e poi la
somiglianza guardate gli occhi no vabbè
parola che sguardo sensuale guarda come
ti provoca in camera
il suo nome utente su tik tok è uno
scioglilingua smooth goffo troppo poco
magari arrivato il momento di mettere un
nome utente un pochino più facile anche
per magari le tue fan
subito no passiamo alla sosia di camila
cave io sto parlando di aisha martinez
che in questa foto ragazzi non è aisha
martinez camila meglio perchè c'è
guardatela ha lo stesso sguardo e lo
stesso viso tutto cioè back è identica
ma andiamo a vedere altre sue foto
entrando nel suo profilo
diciamo che la versione hard di camila
camejo nella sua biografia lei è un ex o
tic dancer
quindi faccio un po fatica a trovare dei
primi piani ma ve li trovo ok c'è questa
che non è proprio un primo piano però è
di spalle così si vede anche il il viso
e anche a livello di corporatura è
abbastanza simile a camila passiamo
all'attore albaro morte che colui che ha
recitato la parte del professor nella
casa di carta il professore ho trovato
ben due sosia del professor 1 su
instagram che uno su tik tok
adesso vi faccio vedere ed ecco a voi
sebastian pure ion chiaramente anche lui
e spagnolo e devo dire che è il
professor cioè nel senso non trovo
differenze a varese la stessa montatura
di occhiali quindi facilita anche le
cose però stessa barba senso capello se
si occhi c'è è impressionante
abbiamo anche dei suoi video come potete
vedere questa è una danza kuduro con
[Risate]
dalla spagna passiamo al paraguay perchè
il secondo sosia che ho trovato su tik
tok
si chiama e il joshua hansen e viene
proprio dal paraguay qui abbiamo il tic
toc famosissimo della scena del ps il
matriarcato inizia il matriarcato dove
lui appunti al telefono con nairobi e
guardate e cioè super super super
somigliante al professor abbiamo anche
la sosia di car dib
si chiama mira cupcake 13 su instagram
assomiglia molto a car dib in alcune
foto un po meno in alcune foto
tantissimo in questa foto che vedete
praticamente identica carpi dice io non
saprei distinguere la pera dalla sosia
stessi occhi stesso naso
stessa cosa stessa bocca ciò è veramente
sconvolgente maccari sua sorella onerosa
qui abbiamo un altro caso sconvolgente
io sono una super fan di shakira quindi
la conosco molto bene e devo dire che la
signorina a schacchi becca su instagram
è veramente identica a shakira ha anche
scelto un nome utente diciamo sobrio
shaki becca quindi ogni riferimento è
puramente casuale capelli uguale tinta
uguale sorriso uguale occhi uguali naso
uguale
in questa foto è l'unica cosa è che lei
è leggermente più gonfia non so se sia
il botox o cosa però la sosia è un
pochino più gonfia in viso rispetto a
shakira ecco voi la fantastica foto di
kate moss la top model più famosa del
mondo non è lei non è lei vi giuro che
non è lei ma è la sosia si chiama hien
not kate moss giustamente su instagram
fa anche lei la modella e mi chiedo come
possa fare questo lavoro essendo
identica kate moss è normale hanno la
stessa forma della bocca stessi occhi
bellissima donna però secondo me non so
magari prima aveva un naso che la
differenzia molto da kate moss qui per
essere più somigliante fermo si è
rifatta al naso un po più piccolino
edoardo viii fa notare che anche un po
lo strabismo di venere che è una
caratteristica appunto che anche il
mosso
voi non avete idea di quello che ho
visto per far vedere
prego regia e jennifer lopez e jennifer
loperz ragazzi dei scioccante questa
cosa siamo tutti d'accordo però che la
signorina coni e pena o pegna credo sia
identica jennifer lopez
vediamo un altro video quella in
spiaggia che lei utilizza una coda finta
di quelle che si mette gelo appiccicate
qua stesso viso stesso naso nelle labbra
forse ha riempito un po con l'acido
ialuronico però per il resto è identica
già che ci siamo andiamo a dare
un'occhiata anche al suo profilo
instagram pala venezia di 202 mila
follower quindi ammazza artista latina
ballerina e cantante anche lei come
quella di kate moss non deve essere
facile provare a fare la cantante quando
sei identica un'altra cantante ho anche
trovato soltanto per voi e soprattutto
per i fan di demi la sosia di demi
lovato che vi toccherà anche qui perché
voglio dire è uguale a demi lovato si
chiama paloma silva ha 23 anni è un
influencer ed è ovviamente anche la
sosia di denis rovato lei stessa lo
sostiene perché perché guardate guardate
la somiglianza spaventosa il sorriso a
me sembra identico c'è lei gli occhi
pure se devo trovare proprio qualcosa di
diverso il naso forse lei ce l'ha
leggermente un po più grosso rispetto ad
amy poi anche l'ovale del viso i capelli
tutto il resto è identico chiudiamo in
bellezza con ania taylor joy che è
l'attrice che ha interpretato il ruolo
della regina degli scacchi
lei si chiama fox spirit cosplay in su
instagram è proprio una cosplayer quindi
ha ricreato perfettamente la foto la
famosissima foto ha fatto il giro del
mondo
d
della regina degli scacchi così davanti
alla sua scacchiera e devo dire che
anche qui l'occhio è identico le labbra
pure il naso secondo me anche solo che
lei nella foto l'alzato leggermente di
più invece anni aveva il volto proprio
abbassato quindi io do un 10 a questa
sosia guardate l'originale guardate la
sosia e ditemi se questa cosa che ci
siano persone in giro per il mondo
identiche da altre persone non vi
affascina da un lato e vi turba
dall'altro fatemi sapere sotto nei
commenti quali sosia che hanno scioccato
sconvolto turbato tolto il sonno più di
tutti e fatemi sapere se volete una
terza parte se avete dei soci ed a
segnalarmi iscrivetevi in direct su
instagram inviatemi nome la foto o il
nome del profilo del sosia
io vi mando un bacio enorme ci vediamo
al prossimo video e ricordatevi di
seguirmi su tutti tutti gli altri
sociali ciao
adoro